I think you're gonna like this story
it's from our favorite fox news show Fox
and Friends I'm gonna set it up for you
five Isis leaders were recently captured
by the American military okay Donald
Trump our fearless orange leader tweeted
about it on Thursday of last week Donald
Trump tweeting five most wanted leaders
of Isis just captured now of course if
Trump's talking about it there's a good
chance Fox & Friends is going to talk
about it and of course Fox and Friends
did talk about it the next day they made
a whole show out of talking about how
the New York Times didn't report about
the capture of these via the killing
rather of these capture not the killing
the capture of these five Isis leaders I
guess they were implying that because
the New York Times doesn't like Trump
they're gonna cover up anytime that
Trump does something good even though
it's not really clear what Trump did to
capture the five Isis leaders anyway
here's one of their hosts I can't even
keep up with who's on that show at this
point this is Pete hagseth making fun of
the New York Times for not covering the
story this is on Friday okay
yes well thank you how did you find
anything during headlines I looked for
the five Isis leaders captured in the
failing New York Times
you're still look and in the print
edition today I have not seen it yet but
we don't need that because we do see
notably nonplussed by had the reference
to the failing New York Times look at
that terrible fake news anti-trump bias
Trump tweeted about it Thursday and Fox
and Friends covered it on Friday and the
New York Times just ignored it except
that the New York Times actually
reported on at first on Wednesday night
on their website and then Thursday
morning in their print edition we
actually have a screenshot from
Wednesday evening in the New York Times
five top Isis officials captured in u.s.
Iraqi sting turns out Fox and Friends
had the wrong newspaper shocker right
these people dictate policy okay Trump
watches Fox and Friends
this is state-run media or media runs
or state and media basically being the
same thing call it whatever you want
governance by idiocy is a better phrase
for it I think and someone pointed out
to me David listen Fox News knew they
were lying because Peter Hedgepeth or
whatever the guys name is said I don't
see it in the print edition meaning he
knew and they all knew that it was
online and probably they knew that it
was in a print edition for the previous
day also and we see this and we think
how dumb how silly who could be
influenced by this degree of
incompetence on Fox and Friends but
people eat this right up and you will
meet people who might not even know that
this talking point the New York Times
didn't cover the ISIS capture they might
not even know it came from Fox News or
Fox & Friends
but they'll say when you talk to them
Trump is winning he got Isis leaders
nobody talks about it the New York Times
doesn't talk about it and they obviously
wouldn't know because they certainly
don't read the New York Times so they
just listen to Pete hedge pats or
whatever this guy's name is I don't know
why I can't remember his name claim
about it is true and now I have the
correction for you right I'm gonna play
for you the video of Fox and Friends
issuing a correction about their claim
oh that's right the video doesn't exist
because they never issued such a
correction this is dangerous stuff Pat
people are falling for this stuff and
this is how these ideas get started it's
not a big deal right oh the New York
Times didn't talk about this thing well
they did but then it becomes part of the
narrative as to why the New York Times
can't be trusted and Fox and Friends
Kent yeah and you could tell that the
host was trying to play this off as an
off-the-cuff idea like right just
spontaneously came up with it yeah that
wordsmith thing I think is very telling
got it to moat this guy get Brian
Kilmeade back on the show he'll do us
justice yeah but and maybe this was III
seriously have no idea what's going on
over on that program at this point
whether it's that that I know that they
have different weekend weekend yeah but
this was Friday morning and Steve Doocy
is there and then also this this other
woman who looks sort of familiar to me I
don't know what's going on with that
program but what's clear is Trump loves
it and this is it's shockingly one of
the most powerful programs in corporate
media at this time because of the extent
to which the president is watching this
show on a regular basis
from the White House let's take a break
coming up next a former Scientologists
Laurie Hudson is back on the program she
had one of our top scientology
interviews we've ever done several years
ago a lot of crazy stuff is going on
with Laurie she's gonna join me next
today's program is made possible in part
by Warby Parker eyeglasses which I now
have two pairs of Warby Parker offers a
free five day in-home trial of their
glasses you try five pairs you see which
you like I wear contact lenses on the
show but I often wear glasses at night
and on weekends and both of my pairs of
Warby Parker glasses are great I did the
free at-home trial
I picked five frames that I liked on
their website they sent them to me I
picked the one I liked the most sent
them back typed in my prescription
online and soon I got my finished
glasses with my prescription in the mail
and I love this because when I'm at a
glasses store trying on glasses I can't
really figure out if I like them because
I feel the pressure of the salespersons
gaze on me I want to show the glasses to
other people I need time to figure out
which glasses I want to commit to and
the eyeglass industry is also controlled
by a tiny number of companies which
keeps prices very high I even know
people who have spent over three hundred
dollars for a pair of glasses but with
Warby Parker there start at just $95
that's what mine costs to try the five
pairs and support the David Pakman show
go to war V Parker trial comm /t DPS